flüchtlingskrise corona-krise
Energiekrise wir leben wirklich in einen
Krisen ein krisenjahrzehnt Nacheinander
und eigentlich wissen die Politiker vor
allem die Regierungspolitiker die Bürger
ernst nehmen ihren Sorgen auffangen und
genau das finde ich ist ist in den
letzten Jahren nicht passiert seit 2015
bis heute besonders der corona-pandemie
hat man das gesehen als Menschen die
Skepsis hatten was ja erstmal legitim
ist sofort als Querdenker pauschal
verurteilt wurden und an den Rand
gedrängt wurden bis hin zu ja irgendwie
Hände von Extremisten geschubst genau
das ist so passiert man konnte das
Beobachten und jetzt gibt es neue
Wahlumfragen in Thüringen 30% würden die
AFD wählen das ist erschrecken und auch
in Sachsen die neuesten Umfragen gehen
auch darauf hinaus nähern sich an die
30% seit September und das die das ist
die Quittung davon und wir stecken jetzt
wieder in einer neuen migrationskrise
die teilweise auch gar nicht so benannt
wird und es trifft besonders wieder
gewachsen und Thüringen und das stärker
als 2015 wenn man sich die Zahlen
wirklich anschaut die Kapazitäten werden
knapp und man hat das Gefühl die
Politiker nehmen das nicht ernst von
Beginn an hat unsere
bundesinnenministerin gesagt wir hätten
keinen Kontrollverlust und eigentlich
dieses herunterspielen zieht sich bis
heute fort und das sehen wir dann in den
Wahlergebnissen wie wir es jetzt haben
erschreckend Zara also du sagst die
Regierung hat eine Mitschuld hört nicht
richtig zu kümmert sich nicht um die
Sorgen der Menschen ja man hat das ja
gesehen solche während der
corona-pandemie dass die Menschen
erstmal Skepsis hatten besonders in den
Ländern wie Thüringen und Sachsen die ja
historisch besonders sensibel vorgeprägt
sind das muss man ja auch so sagen und
da gab es halt sofort die Zurufe von
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen sind
ganz schnell ja das sind ja alles
Querdenker die sind alles rechts und man
hat diese Menschen damit er erst recht
an den Rand gedrückt und ähnlich ist es
eigentlich mit der flüchtlingskrise
gewesen sei vor 2015 in der wir immer
noch stecken und die auch gerade Ste
wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt und das
zum Beispiel wenn Morde passiert sind
wie wir es jetzt auch in einer Kirchberg
sehen von einem Asylbewerber mutmaßlich
aus Eritrea das zum Beispiel
Priorisierung stattfinden also solche
Morde werden dann weniger von der
Regierung thematisiert als zum Beispiel
rechtsextremistische Taten und diese
Priorisierungen diese Politik auch das
Verschweigens und tauisieren von
wichtigen Debatten die in der Mitte
stattfinden müssen führt natürlich dazu
auch das gewisse Leute dann die AFD
wählen weil die AFD diese Themen die ja
auch heiß sind diese Themen muss man ja
aufpassen das muss man stark
differenzieren für sich vereinnahmen
können und die Menschen ja zu sich
bringen ihre Partei regiert mit verliert
man zu sehr die Sorgen der Menschen aus
den Augen haben Sie eine andere
Erklärung für die Zeit
also es ist richtig dass man die
Probleme so benennen muss wie sie sind
und es ist auch richtig dass in der
Pandemie zu viel Ausgrenzung
stattgefunden hat gegenüber Menschen die
Maßnahmen kritisiert haben ich habe das
selber ein Stück weiter erlebt weil ich
die Maßnahmen gegenüber Kindern sehr
stark kritisiert haben war dann schnell
im querdenkerlager wo ich absolut nicht
hingehöre
trotzdem muss man auch sehen historisch
gesehen Thüringen ist ein Land komme ich
dann doch mal in die Geschichte rein das
erste Land damals auf dem Weg zu macht
Ergreifung es gab Demokratie
Feindlichkeit Einstellungen auch schon
seit langer Zeit die gibt es dort und da
kann ich dann auch nicht sagen ich habe
für alles Verständnis dann einfach auch
schlecht da muss man dann auch mit
Aufklärung und mit Gesprächen reingehen
und manchmal auch sagen Stopp halt die
Mehrheit sitzt dann doch anders was
jetzt den Fall in Iller Kirchberg angeht
aber unsere stadtsekretärin ist mehrere
Tage vor Ort die kennt sogar die Familie
persönlich also wir haben uns da schon
auch direkt gekümmert gesagt ja dazu
sich nicht geäußert hat
quasi von Deutschland hat sich dazu
nicht ja gut die Frage ist was hat er
sich zu jedem Mord macht das ja also das
weiß ich nicht ja also das ist ja ein
sehr furchtbarer Mord gewesen der hat
ganz Deutschland bewegt also wenn da
nicht unser Bundeskanzler etwas dazu
sagen muss dann weiß ich auch nicht
aber ich kann nicht für ihn sprechen ich
kann nur sagen dass wir das schon
themaisiert haben das nicht nur also wir
haben das nicht nur bei den
Regierungsparteien wir haben das auch
lange gehabt bei der vorherigen
Regierungspartei CDU
ja eine Volkspartei die auch hätte die
Bürger auffangen müssen und sie hat
lange Themen z.B Integrationspolitik
Themen lieber der AFD überlassen weil
sie Angst hatten dann als Rechten zu
gelten und deswegen wurde ganz lange
auch keine Debatte aus der politischen
Mitte geführt und das spürten das merken
natürlich auch die Bürger und das
Erspüren sie und gerade wenn jetzt so
derzeit der Asylbereich steigt an die
Grenzen und Ukraine schon seit Juni
übrigens ähm runter geht und ganz stark
steigt dann kommt da natürlich Fragen
auf und das sieht spiegelt sich in den
Wahlergebnisse wieder
Zwiebeln bei uns die großen
erfolgsparteien befürchten sie dass es
in Deutschland einen Rechtsruck geben
könnte so wie wir es in anderen
europäischen Ländern sehen
beispielsweise in Italien ja
mittelfristig kann man nichts
ausschließen kurzfristig sehe ich das
nicht das sind jetzt Umfragen vor einer
Landtagswahl die in anderthalb Jahren
sein wird glaube ich oder noch weiterhin
die bundesweit sieht auch nicht gut aus
15,5 Prozent hat Demokratie Parteien die
nicht verboten sind die darf man auch
wählen also man könnte jetzt auch über
27 % für die Linkspartei im in Thüringen
mache ich auch nicht da würde ich sagen
warte mal die Wahlen ab aber wo sie
natürlich schon Punkt macht und das ist
glaube ich schon eine Verantwortung die
der jetzigen ampelregierung auch zukommt
und vor allem den Grünen und der SPD
dass sie abweichende Meinungen zu
schnell diffamiert einfach also wer sagt
ich will über die migrationskrise
sprechen der wird doch sehr schnell als
Ausländer Feind geframt die Familie
denunziert wer sagt wir haben einen
migrationskrise der wird als jemand die
Familie der sagen will wir müssen uns
abschotten vielleicht Grenzanlagen bauen
also wird wahnsinnig übertrieben die
vermehrungsoperation von Seiten der
Grünen von von Seiten der SPD dazu sagen
wir sind dafür viele Leute vor Ort wir
gehen dahin wir schauen uns das an wir
wollen auch nicht dass dort Verbrechen
passieren warum sind die passiert dann
müssen wir aufklären und nicht zu sagen
da reden wir jetzt erstmal nicht drüber
Willkommenskultur ist uns vielleicht
wichtiger als innere Sicherheit der
Eindruck wird vermittelt Frau Fesser war
bei diesem Anschlag auf einen ein
Flüchtlingsheim in Norddeutschland ist
ja nach als brandstation glaube ich
herausgestellt hat ohne politisches
Motiv da war sie am nächsten Tag jetzt
hat sie dort ein relativ
formalhaften Tweet abgesetzt das war's
dann aber auch es war im Bundestag kaum
Thema bei den Regierungsparteien oder
nur im Nebensatz und das merken Leute
natürlich mit deshalb stehen wir sicher
vor einem kompletten Kippen des Systems
überhaupt nicht aber wenn immer mehr
Leute den Eindruck haben ich erlebe
diese Wirklichkeit auf den Straßen in
den Großstädten in meinem Dorf und dann
sagt mir die Politik ach ist gar nicht
so schlimm wir finden neue
Unterkunftsmöglichkeiten und übrigens
bleiben wir angekommenes Land für alle
Menschen die zu uns kommen wollen dann
klappt einfach diese Lücke zwischen eine
Wahrnehmung der Realität vieler Bürger
und den Parolen der Regierenden und wenn
diese Lücke immer größer wird dann kann
irgendwann auch mal irgendwann auch mal
unter dem ins Rutschen kommen wie plant
die Regierung diese Lücke zu schließen
sie haben selbst gesagt die Vermehrung
das große Wort sie gerade auch benutzt
haben haben sie erlebt in der
corona-krise als sie eine andere
Position eingenommen haben sogar von der
eigenen Partei muss man sich zum
Beispiel da Entschuldigung
Entschuldigung wird es helfen wenn man
sich entschuldigen würde für die Fehler
in der corona-krise könnte das helfen
diese Lücke ein bisschen mehr zu
schließen das Problem mit der
corona-krise ist dass er fast keine
Mitte mehr zu finden war in der
Diskussion und auch diejenigen die dann
gegen die Maßnahmen protestiert haben
viele von ihnen würde ich sagen haben
völlig überzogen in der Haltung das ist
dann nur noch um Freiheit gegen gar
nicht mehr am Schutz oder nur um Schutz
und nicht im Freiheit das ist ja völlig
unter komplex und ich glaube wir sind
alle traumatisiert als Gesellschaft und
es wäre in der Tat gut wenn auch
diejenigen die für sehr strenge
Maßnahmen waren und jetzt auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister einmal
zugegeben hat das Kita Schließung und da
kann man auch ehrlich gesagt auch sagen
gleich Grundschule Schließung
keine super Events waren und auch falsch
waren dass man immer sagt ich bin der
falsch gelegen und ich entschuldige mich
dafür anstatt zu sagen das ist jetzt so
und ich hätte es damals besser wissen
können oder nicht ja also das ist eine
Frage von Debatten Stil jetzt was
Kitzler gesagt hat ich würde die
Realität nicht ganz so beschreiben wie
sie haben wir jetzt wirklich in ganz
Deutschland gravierende Probleme im
Bereich einer migrationskrise nicht
überall wir haben also wir haben
natürlich Herausforderungen wir müssen
noch die Themen ein bisschen drin also
wir haben natürlich übrigens
westbalkanroute Thema da sind wir auch
selber unterwegs und sagen wir wollen
dass da was passiert das nicht mehr
Leute noch zu uns kommen ist auch ab
Haltung der Regierung auf der anderen
Seite haben wir das Thema Fachkräfte
Zuwanderung das ist völlig klar dass wir
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht
ohne Zuwanderung unser Wohlstand halten
können und die Wirtschaft ist damit uns
auf einer Seite also wir werden auch
Leute mehr brauchen wir brauchen auch
eine andere Willkommenskultur dass Leute
sich auch willkommen es wandern viel zu
viel Leute ab ja aus Deutschland und es
gibt kriminelle aber es gibt auch
deutsche kriminelle Leute
gar nicht deutschland ist für Fachkräfte
ist attraktiv momentan für Leute die die
Sozialleistungen zu schätzen wissen weit
Gebühr und das ist schon ein Problem und
die Grünen und die FDP die Grünen und
die SPD vor allem haben finde ich keinen
scharfen Blick auf die Schattenseiten
der Migration die ist eben auch gibt
nicht nur aber die gibt's doch auch ich
kann doch nicht sagen jeder einzelne
Mensch der hier kommt ist eine
Bereicherung natürlich nicht er kann es
sein er muss aber nicht sein es kommt ja
nicht eine moralische besten Auslese zu
uns und das wird aber immer für diesen
scharfen Befürwortern dann ist Kultur so
vertreten auf jeden Menschen dankbar
sein müssen das ist einfach würde das
nicht so sehen dass wir das so sagen und
auch nicht aber sie sehen das anders ist
wir sind ja auch ein Bund gemischtes
Land also ich kenne in meiner
Verwandtschaft auch Menschen wo ich
sagen würde okay das würde mir die
Willkommenskultur vielleicht schwer
machen das ist aber nicht weil aus dem
Ausland kommt sondern es gibt halt
schwierige Menschen gibt nicht
schwierige Menschen ich will was
erzählen was mir heute passiert ist in
dem Zusammenhang was mir viel mehr
Sorgen dann macht ich saßen Kaffee
trinken und in so einem Geschäft und
dann kam ein alterer her und wollte sich
dazu setzen und dann saß aber da ein
bisschen weiter weg ein Mensch weiß
unklar
der sah so vor seinem Handy laut am
Reden hat sich mit jemand unterhalten ja
und dann sagte er während er wollte sich
da überlegt ob er sich zu mir setzt oder
wo er sich jetzt hinsetzt weil da war es
halt laut und dann sage ich wollte sich
zu mir setzen sagt dann nee auch nicht
und dann macht er folgenden Scherz sagt
er naja man weiß ja auch nicht ob da
nicht ein Messer in der Tasche hat
da sitzt ein Mensch in einem Café an dem
Tisch und redet vielleicht etwas laut
und das einzige was ihm als ältere
Mensch durch den Kopf geht ist man weiß
ja nicht ob dein Messer in der Tasche
hat in dich fragte ihn nur wie kommen
Sie denn auf die Idee und das sagte ja
in Berlin hat sieben Messer ermorde
gegeben meinte müssen mal rechnen wie
viel verkehrsto ist gerade gegeben hat
aber es seine Wahrnehmung der Welt ist
von Medien geprägt um mich herumlaufen
Messer schleifende Ausländer oder sowas
da steht natürlich eine Überforderung
dieses Beispiel auch wenn sowas passiert
ich will einmal noch kommen zur einer
weiteren Sorge die glaube ich viele
gerade jetzt quält steigende Gaspreise
dann ab Januar oder Ölpreis viele schon
in den Geldbeutel in seinem Po ich weiß
es gar nicht wie wir hier durch diesen
Winter kommen wie real ist diese Angst
für Sie
für mich gar nicht ich lebe sehr sparsam
ich bin bei Energiewerke Schönau die
sind in Strom sehr günstig
Kinder oder nein nicht ich habe zwei
Kinder aber meine Tochter da es wird ein
bisschen wärmer gemacht die brauchst ein
bisschen wärmer aber wenn ich dann die
alten Menschen sehe die überall sind
dann freue ich mich dass ich in einer
der günstigsten Wohngenossenschaften in
Berlin untergekommen bin die also bei
fünf Nacken knapp 6 € kalt liegt in
Berlin wo Studenten 400 € für 10
Quadratmeter zahlen müssen
persönlich gefragt habe aber sie kennen
diese Ohnmacht und diese einzelnen
Umfeld geplante Obsoleszenz sehe ja und
ältere Leute den sozusagen die dünne
Rente durch vorzeitigen Verschleiß aus
der Tasche gezogen wird die sich dann
sagen ich weiß ja gar nicht wo ich die
nächsten Fernseher herkriegen soll und
die Wohnung wird auch immer kälter das
macht mir natürlich extreme Sorgen
ihr großes Thema und da hoffe ich mir
auch ein paar gute Tipps wie man da
überhaupt vorgehen kann oder aufmerksam
sein kann damit man quasi nicht
irgendein Schrott kauft weihnachten
steht ja auch vor der Tür deswegen darf
aber sie sagen wir kommen gut durch
diese Krise sie sagen all die Menschen
die sich fürchten jetzt in den
Geldbeutel schauen wirklich Sorge haben
sagen Sie können alle auf atmen ich
glaube schon dass wir jetzt ziemliche
Stabilität reinbringen für die
VerbraucherInnen also wir haben die
Strom und die gaspreisbremse heute
beschlossen
ja und wir haben auch entlastet dieses
Jahr 95 Milliarden in drei Paketen das
insbesondere an die Haushalte geht die
geringe Einkommen haben oder gar keine
Einkommen
also da ist was passiert dass Leute
verunsichert sind und das ist immer auch
Härtefälle gibt das ist so das muss man
sich dann im Einzelfall noch mal
anschauen aber die Sorgen die man haben
konnte noch vor drei oder vier Monaten
die sind so nicht eingetroffen und wenn
es notwendig ist werden wir auch im
kommenden Jahr weiter entlasten das muss
einfach gemacht werden ehrlich gesagt
ein Problem was wir haben wir können das
nicht machen was die Amerikaner machen
können nämlich einen direkten Scheck mal
an die Leute geben die direkt Auszahlung
zu machen weil wir die Digitalisierung
in Deutschland nicht vorangetrieben
haben deswegen mussten wir jetzt ein
sehr komplexes Gesetz mit einer Strom-
und gaspreisbremse machen also so eine
direkte Entlastung und dann auch gezielt
an Menschen mit geringen Einkommen das
wäre das wäre doch extrem